ces rivières sébastien et cathy et du
bien on épouse
diane hypothèses estimations finition la
petite touche remis à charmant bourg les
saveurs d'une intense et une entreprise
qui existe depuis 2013 on faisait
exclusivement les fêtes
à la réunion avec les marchés et on
s'est dit aujourd'hui qu'on souhaiterait
faire d'exploitation est vraiment veniez
en proposer nos produits ce marché
français et européen si si tout se passe
bien alors il y aura il ya h argos après
l'achat de mama fillon ici
tout est fait ma hanche et à la main peu
très peu de machines chez nous
pour le format
à la fois
et puisqu'on apprend pour le salon tous
passionnés seront cette année serait
qu'ils attribuent pékin et
la crème de patates douces aux fruits de
la passion
à déguster avec des crêpes à tartiner ou
même mangé la petite cuillère